yeah we were so nervous he's
miming the words with dogs
he knows everybody's lying
that's my father
willie willie style philly style we are
here to see which
fresh prince character we really are
[Music]
how would your bff describe you outgoing
respectful caring confident independent
wise loyal
outgoing i'm our bff so
outgoing caring independent lord all of
these independent independent
independent my person would say
wise
outgoing
i would say also
outgoing uh only one answer yeah okay
got it
okay okay okay this is what happened
next one is pick a guest star from the
original series tyra banks don cheadle
queen latifah chris rock nia long heavy
d
oprah sherman hemsley i think i'm gonna
pick sherman hemsley i'm picking heavy d
okay there we go i mean i picked chris
rock don cheadle that's a good choice oh
you know i'm a big fan of that i i
already picked up don yeah yeah he
played trey and that episode where he
sits with will and you see you see him
doing his lines and looking at will's
lips go
oh
that's the one where will was
so nervous he's
miming the words with dogs like right he
knows everybody's lying you see don't
cheaters this guy what is this actor
doing you don't know who my dad don
cheadle is
that's my father right his name that's
my father okay i'm a girl
yeah i'ma go with mia long because i
also have a secret crush on spot which
superlative best describes you in school
class clown most likely to follow the
rules best dressed best dancer biggest
flirt best smile most likely to succeed
most likely to change the world oh my
gosh myself
most likely to change the world do
nothing gash yourself give me a what
chance
this is live you can got yourself class
clown
i for me it would be class clown
i blame the fresh prince of bel air for
that as well yeah i love will's
character how much fun he would have and
i would do that in my classroom i was a
good dancer i was i was probably one of
them okay that makes sense i'll i'll say
a best dancer
i got best dressed as my superlative in
high school really yeah i got better
okay
i don't know i feel like probably most
likely
i'm definitely
i've
biggest
flirt
no i've worked here i've worked really
really hard to not be that way anyway
i'm gonna say probably um
most likely to succeed as well it's game
night which 90s fashion item are you
rocking detailed vests oversized hat
oversized button-up shirt colorful
blazer oversized jean jacket tracksuit
overalls tank top it'd be between that
track suit and that detailed vest i'm
gonna go with tdfs i remember i had so
many vests that i was like what what
does this say about me okay so we're
gonna do detail the best i rock the best
a lot too actually really yeah yeah i i
used to love like the overalls like that
dungarees thing yeah you know that sort
of house
yeah and crisscross you know it'd be
backwards overalls and all that yeah
yeah the bad guy was big into the
baggage track suit you know i was going
to say track suit i was going to say
traxxas i love that i think i go it's a
game night you know what i mean we're
chilling i'm gonna go to tracksuit now
okay okay
i'm tank top i love a good tank top i
love my arms and i like
showing people i'm going to say
oversized jean jacket do a lot of
property
now choose a 90s slang term or phrase to
bring back all that on a bag of chips
the bomb of
bugging talk to the hand oh goodness
tripping
word
ass f
getting jiggy
girls i feel like you're just getting
jiggy mind i was going to say i'm
thinking about the go ahead get jiggy
with it mine's bugging looking feels
like you guys
i got the bug eyes that's why you
wouldn't do all the other bag of chips
no i don't feel like that's like coco
would say that she's like you all bat
you all that in a baggage too i could
say that like yeah i think you want a
bag of [ __ ]
i would say all that and a bag of chips
because it for me it reminds me of the
uk we wouldn't call fries fries we would
call them a bag of chips i bring that
word so i could be worse okay and
finally your turn
and finally
[Music]
and finally pick a will smith movie to
watch tonight we got men in black bad
boys too pursuit of happiness
king richard aladdin pitch suicide squad
bad boys too oh
that voice 2 is like so good but hitch
is like the the perfect sweet spot
romantic the thing is you can't really
go wrong with any of these i'm honestly
going to say hitch because i just think
there are some hilarious moments like
when he kicks her on that jet skate
i'm like ah i'm gonna go king richard he
got the nomination maybe aladdin i think
i'ma go for pursuit of happiness because
uh jabari and i are gonna do
a reboot of pursuit of happiness he's
gonna play will and i'm gonna play jaden
i'd watch aladdin tonight you know why
because i have a three-year-old pursuit
of happiness you know that that's what
you'd watch tonight yeah it's a
beautiful movie i wish i am legend was
on here oh that was one yeah but i would
go with ali
will smith will smith will smith i got
on this i got willy big willy willy
style philly style personality matches
will smith you're outgoing zestful
passionate like will you're all about
creating new memories and making the
most of any situation you have an
optimistic view on life which is why
your friends and family can always count
on you to bring the sunshine during the
darkest days wow
wait that was accurate i'm the greatest
human lol i got hillary i got ashley
uh i
also got ashley banks i'm on the a
vision of grace and black excellence
your personality matches on viv you're
carrying forthright and understanding
like on viv you're a natural nurturer
you've probably been told on multiple
occasions that you have a big heart and
that's because you radiate kindness and
warmth you're often looked at as the mom
of the friend group that's not true
because you go above and beyond for
those you love
you do go away you know they always have
their best interests at heart okay well
we just finished up the fresh prince
character quiz be sure to check out bel
air okay but do it again but be a little
bit more will smith be more will smith
hey oh okay uh
all right uh we want y'all to check out
bel air
it's gonna be
the ball
[Applause]
thank you buzzfeed
you